Speaker 1: I'm going to show you some stunning
video here. Propagandist Sean HANNITY and radical,
repugnant, reactionary Republican Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert got into it last night on Fox
News. Sean HANNITY increasingly seems sick of this
contingent of MAGA that is holding up what could
be republicans picking a speaker and getting
everybody sworn in and moving forward. This is
really good. This is the self-destructive nature
of this party that is unable to govern, that
doesn't care about policy, that is obsessed with
cultural issues and going anti-woke and all of
this nonsense. This came to a head last night when
Lauren Boebert appeared with Sean HANNITY, and
HANNITY went right after her. And I have to say,
HANNITY makes some statistically good points here,
and I'll explain in a moment. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: You said complimentary things about
President Trump needs to tell Kevin McCarthy
that, sir. You do not, sir. It's time to withdraw.
Let me turn the tables, Congresswoman. Kevin
McCarthy is 202 three votes. Your side has 20.
So if I'm going to use your words and your
methodology and your math, is it a time for
you to pack it in and your side to pack it in?
Considering he has over 200 and you have 20?
Speaker 1: Now, this is, strictly speaking, true.
HANNITY is completely correct. If you want to talk
about who's being stubborn or obstinate or holding
this up despite not having the numbers on their
hands, it is a sort of tyranny of this minority of
the Republican Party. Most of the Republican Party
is united, but the rules are the rules. But the
frustration that HANNITY is experiencing, because
this is becoming a clown show, is well placed.
Speaker 3: Sean, I understand the frustration,
I promise you. But I'm not.
Speaker 2: Frustrated. You
didn't answer my question.
Speaker 3: We are hearing we
are hearing from frustrated who are
still voting with Kevin McCarthy.
Speaker 2: You're not answering my question.
Speaker 3: Of what we're doing and they're
cheering us on. So there are more for
us than are against us. And they are
waiting for Kevin to with the American
Congress almost certainly frustrated by.
Speaker 2: I'm frustrated by you not answering
a direct question. You said to President Abbas,
you said earlier today that President Trump
needs to tell Kevin McCarthy you don't have
the votes to come up with. Can I finish?
Speaker 3: Candidate to elect.
Can I finish the house?
Speaker 2: You don't have the
votes and it's time to withdraw. He has 203. Your
side has 20. Why is it time for him to withdraw
and not you when he has so many more votes?
Speaker 3: Well, Sean, he needs to 18 and he
does not have to 18. We've been trying to, you
know, in private, as you said, for months. But
Kevin McCarthy didn't even want to listen to us
until his disappointing midterms. We all want.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Sean HANNITY making a
perfectly fine point. It is also completely
okay for a Republican who doesn't want Kevin
McCarthy to be speaker, not to vote for him, but
they need to understand the consequences. That's
for them to figure out. Then Lauren Boebert says,
maybe I should nominate Donald Trump tomorrow.
And at this point, HANNITY just says, what? You're
turning this into a game show at this point is.
Speaker 2: Your final choice for speaker. And
if you can't get more than, let's say, 30
votes, will you follow your own advice that
you were asking Donald Trump and withdrawal?
Speaker 3: There are certainly names that
are being floated around and hey, maybe I
should nominate President Donald J. Trump
tomorrow. But, Sean, I did watch your show.
Speaker 2: Last game show like we're going.
Speaker 3: To paint on this motion.
Speaker 2: We're going to pick Jim Jordan
one day, Donald Trump the next day.
Speaker 3: It's motion to vacate.
Speaker 1: HANNITY is actually correct in
assessing the cartoonish and childish nature of
some elements of this. And this kept going.
Speaker 2: We don't have.
Speaker 3: Priority, not Sean, I will not
withdraw our. We're we're not petty of
Kevin McCarthy. They were not self-serving. We
simply were asking for commitments on what the
American people want to see. They want to see a
vote on term limits, a vote on the Texas border
plan to secure the southern border.
Speaker 2: Congresswoman, all due.
Speaker 3: Respect, we asked
for a vote on a budget that
actually all viewers should imagine. Imagine
a Congress that's not so. If you only have 30.
Speaker 2: People supporting.
Speaker 3: Your right and we are
going to get the right speaker.
Speaker 2: If you only have 30
to be clear, you will not withdraw.
Speaker 3: It'll be a beautiful night.
Speaker 2: But you're telling Kevin McCarthy
and the and the 203 people that support him
to withdraw because they don't have
to. 18. That's what you're saying.
Speaker 3: Look, it's obvious by tonight's motion
to adjourn that Kevin McCarthy and his supporters
are already getting voter fatigue.
Speaker 2: And I asked you
a simple question, Congresswoman.
Speaker 1: I she's not going to answer it. And
Sean HANNITY is right to point out that she's not
answering it. Sean HANNITY is no better, Right. I
don't want Sean HANNITY in charge of the House any
more than I want Lauren Boebert in charge of the
House. But the important thing that is of interest
to us here is that this is really, really bad for
them. Now, it's also bad for the country. Let's
take it in two parts later. I'll tell you why this
is so bad for the country and why it's a national
security risk. That's the that's one component in
terms of the Republican Party. This undermines
their unity and cohesion in a literal sense.
Democrats are completely united saying, we want
Hakeem Jeffries, we're all behind Hakeem Jeffries,
and you guys are running a clown show. On the
Republican side. The Republicans are divided. They
look disorganized. They're it's Byron Donalds,
and then it's Jim Jordan. And then maybe Boebert
wants Trump or whatever. So this will damage
their reputation. It will make it less likely
they achieve their goals if and when they finally
select a speaker, which I think is great. Their
goals are horrible. I don't want them to achieve
their goals. It distracts from issues. Presumably
they would want to be working on. It diverts time
and energy away from things they want to be doing,
which is great. I don't want them doing the things
they want to do. It can lead to a really prolonged
period of uncertainty and instability, and that
is where it starts to become a national concern.
And we'll talk about that a little bit later. And
then as far as the atmosphere within their party,
it's getting extraordinarily toxic. And again,
I'm I'm saying why it's bad for them. I want it
to be bad for them. But the atmosphere, their
relationships, trust between members, oh,
we're we're going to support Jordan and Donald
and this that the other thing and hopefully it
will lead to a prolonged power struggle once this
is done. And I'm guessing we've got another day or
two of this. I don't know, but I could be wrong.
I thought we'd have a speaker on Tuesday. This
could lead to a continued power struggle over the
next two years, which is great. And then lastly,
if they finally get a speaker under these types
of circumstances, it will be a speaker whose
credibility and authority are not going to be
solid. It is a very different thing to say We
all want Hakeem Jeffries. Hakeem Jeffries is
the speaker. The authority and credibility of
Jeffries is untainted versus we had six, eight, 12
votes shifting around support for alternatives to
McCarthy. We eventually acquiesce. If that's what
happens, that hurts the credibility and authority
of the speaker, which again, is bad for them. So
I hope all of these things happen. HANNITY seems
to recognize that this is the way the ball is
increasingly rolling. I'm sure many of you will
have questions about this issue and others during
our upcoming viewer townhall. It is Wednesday,
January 11th, at 6 p.m. Eastern on our Discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. It will
be streaming live. Everyone is invited to
participate. Members on our website will get
priority access to me on the Wednesday town hall.
You can of course sign up at join Packman dot com.
Lest anyone be confused, The David Pakman Show is
still supported by our audience in 2023. I would
love for you to sign up. Join Pacman dot com. Not
only will you be directly supporting a program
that hopefully you find valuable, you also support
all of the other things we're doing, including the
free white paper we've made available at David
Pakman dot com slash guide, the town halls, the
content on new and growing platforms and on and on
and on. You can sign up at join Pacman dot com and
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get yourself a discount.